- [Voiceover] Is each piece equal to
1/4 of the area of the pie?
So we have a pie,
and it has one, two, three, four pieces.
So it does have four pieces.
So is one of those pieces
equal to 1/4 of the pie?
Well let's talk about what we mean
when we have a fraction like 1/4.
The one in the fraction, the numerator,
represents a number of pieces.
So here, one piece.
One piece of pie.
And then the four, when
we're talking about fractions
is always talking about
the number of equal size.
Equal
size
pieces.
So in this case four equal size pieces.
So the question is,
is each piece one of
four equal size pieces?
Let's look at the pie.
I think it's pretty clear
that these pieces on the end
are not equal, they are smaller
than the two pieces in the middle.
If you love cherry pie,
you are not happy about
getting this end piece.
Because it is smaller.
It is not an equal size piece.
So yes, each piece is
one out of four pieces.
But it is not one of
four equal size pieces.
Therefore it is not 1/4.
So our answer is no.
No, no, no.
Each piece is not 1/4
or an equal share of the pie.